thank you very much for being on the
program congratulations on the new job
and we'll get into the reasons for the
appointment in a moment but first if you
could just give us an update on what's
happening with Sudan France deciding to
evacuate their citizens are we going to
do the same
well well thank you Sophie and uh the
situation in a respect of Sudan is
clearly a rapidly moving and complex
situation our priority is to support
British Nationals now the minister of
defense is acting in support of the
foreign office but clearly you wouldn't
expect me to comment for security
reasons on uh the the current situation
in terms of movements on the ground sure
I get you don't want to get into the
details or movement but at the same time
you know the US has said that they're
evacuating different amounts of France
has come out to say they're going to
evacuate Nationals as well are we
looking at evacuating citizens well as I
said we have got uh the the ministry of
defense is supporting uh the the foreign
office you wouldn't expect me to get
into uh what is is going on at a ground
level but what can I what I can say is
that we are first of all they said what
I would say is a very different
situation to for example the situation
that you saw in Afghanistan for a number
of reasons first of all this situation
has arisen uh very rapidly and uh
secondly we just don't have the kind of
uh scale of resources on the ground that
were there in Afghanistan but clearly we
need to make sure that uh we support our
British Nationals at the moment the
advice to to British Nationals is to
make sure they stay indoors that they
they stay safe and that they get in
contact with the foreign office okay
continue course talking to the
government as it goes on to see if that
advice changes or if there's any
movement and more that you can tell us
later
um you're testing an emergency alarm
today what's the thinking behind it
well the the job of government is to
keep people safe it's number one uh job
of government and what we are doing is
we're testing an emergency alert so at
three o'clock this afternoon there will
be a siren like sound for about 10
seconds on people's smartphones is about
the same volume as if your phone was
ringing but I would say to people is
this is just a test you don't need to do
anything it's rather like the fire alarm
test is is a bit irritating at the time
but in future people could be grateful
for it because in a real emergency this
could be the sound that saves your life
forgive me if you
if you're tossing around this right at
three o'clock when people's phones start
blaring out
you're gonna Panic aren't they
uh well I don't think that's the case we
we tested this for example in the
reading area and there were over 140 000
people involved in those very positive
feedback there wasn't any Panic at all
uh I have announced I think on on your
program a couple of weeks ago that this
thing was coming it's very similar to
what happens in other countries whether
that's the United States whether it's uh
the Japan or or Canada they regularly
test these things as well I think it's
another tool in the the toolkit uh I
think most British people in these
situations keep calm and carry on I'm
sure they'll do the same thing again
okay now I don't want to spend too much
time uh talking about migration because
to be honest it feels as if every Sunday
we have another almost identical opinion
piece by swella bravoman saying she's
going to take on the courts and she's
going to get tough on small boats but
there are a couple of facts I think it
would be useful to try and find out
ahead of the illegal migration Bill
coming to the commons this week
is the Home Secretary going to be given
powers to ignore European courts if they
try to stop deportations to Rwanda
well I think you're talking about the
so-called section 39 uh Provisions uh
the the Home Secretary uh will be given
a discretion an ability to look at the
circumstances of that uh order from the
European Court of of Human Rights and
will for example consider factors such
as the timeliness of the uh the the
imposition of the order so for example
if it is done at last minute uh and also
the transparency because underlying all
of this Sophie is the same point and by
the way I've I've been out campaigning a
lot I hear this so much from people
people want us to get control of our
borders stop this file traffic and stop
the boats and this is an important
provision as part of much about the
arguments for and against I'm just
trying to nail down exactly the facts
right so there will be a discussion
given to the Home Secretary to
effectively ignore European court
rulings well there will be a section 39
discretion now I'm not saying that that
will give the the Home Secretary carte
blanche to overall uh rulings what I
would say is that first of all we are
engaging very closely uh with the
European cultures
we're making very good progress but I
think it's right that the Home Secretary
should have a discretion so for example
we don't have this situation where at
the very last minute uh an order is
imposed those are the sort of factors
that the Home Secretary will be able to
consider will there also be a move to
open up more safe and legal routes
because that's something that other
people are really concerned about that
it's very difficult for people to
actually legally claim Asylum
hey yes well the first thing to say is
that uh We've allowed over half a
million people
so it's an important point of a contest
it is an important point of context on
this which is that in this country we've
been able to allow ukrainians Hong Kong
Nationals uh Afghanistan Nationals in
now of course I want us to be able to be
in a situation where we can create more
routes for people to come into this
country
what comes first is making sure that we
get control of our borders and we stop
this vile trafficking of people across
the the English Channel only uh
profiting uh criminal gangs once that's
that control of once we get control of
that
stop the boats then we will have more
capacity to be able to extend our
kindness and generosity as a nation
which I'm very proud of even further
that sounds like a no to me then no move
next week to open up more safe and legal
routes to the UK
um let's move on to other issues because
as I said it feels like every week we're
talking about um this issue
is Dominic Raab a bully
well the Prime Minister asked Adam
Tolley to conduct a detailed
investigation I think it was about 48
pages long he set out the facts of what
happened in a very clear way there's
nothing further I can add to that
interpretation what I can say though is
that Dom promised that if there was an
adverse finding against him he would
resign I've worked with domon uh over a
number of years particularly I remember
the time when he took over from Boris
when he was incapacitated I know that
Dom is a man of his word and he resigned
and as the Prime Minister said I think
that was the right thing to have done he
did he made that promise on this program
that if the bullying complaint was
upheld he would resign so if he hadn't
made that commitment do you think he
would still be in a job
well Sophie that's a hypothetical uh
situation uh the Prime Minister asked
Adam tolly to conduct this situation it
was it was um it was a very
comprehensive piece of work it dealt
with each of the allegations uh against
him and went into the facts of those
the situation as to whether the Prime
Minister had to make a decision on that
didn't arise because Dom had always
promised if it was an adverse finding
against him he would resign he's a man
of his word and he stuck by that would
you like to see him back in cabinet well
I think Dom has
um a huge amount that he has offered at
this country in the past clearly
decisions as to who is in the cabinet or
not are purely The Preserve of the Prime
Minister now Dominic Robb has blamed
activist civil servants who are trying
to block reforms and in The Observer
Today it says the government's
considering allowing ministers greater
powers to appoint their own civil
servants do you think there was a case
for that
well we keep all of these things under
view I think it was actually an article
by Francis Maude who was a predecessor
in the cabinet office and I think it's
important that we we look at Civil
Service uh appointments on an ongoing
basis but I'm pretty confident that uh
at the moment ministers are able to give
clear instructions to civil servants and
to get things done and that has to
continue and I I can say that certainly
there won't be any dropping of my high
standards from the civil servants that
work for me and the reason for that is
that we're here to serve the British
people and we must continue to do you
think that Rob is wrong then to Mr
rather's Wrong then to talk about the
civil servants in the way that he does
because he is talking right about
activists civil servants he's
effectively saying that they're out to
get him
well I didn't live Dom's experience I've
I've served both as an advisor in the
past and for a number of years as a
cabinet minister I've always found that
if you give clear instructions to uh
Civil Service of course you can have
frustrations and believe me I've had my
frustrations as well but I've also seen
for example I think that at the height
of the covid crisis when all of our
theaters were were locking down my civil
servants work Relentless with me
literally with me to get that two
billion pound cultural Recovery Fund
civil servants can deliver but I do not
want to see any diminution in the
ability of ministers to expect high
standards of their officials because in
the end we're serving the British people
and we must continue to I mean it's
important to say that some of the
complaints against Dominic robbed said
that he would behaved in an intimidating
fashion with unreasonably and
persistently aggressive conduct when
you've spoken before about a painful
woke Cycle book psychodrama do you think
the reaction to dominant Rob is an
example of the painful work psychodrama
well I I I think there are many
challenges with uh work and you've seen
many speeches from me uh in the past on
that I think in respect of the the Civil
Service what I have seen is that if you
give clear instructions to to civil
service you can expect uh them to
respond to that and I don't want to see
any change in that because it is
essential that we deliver okay I want to
talk about this quite seriously now
because there have been nine Justice
secretaries since 2015. that's more than
one a year and I think we can just look
now at the state of the Crown Court
backlog I mean the latest figures put
the backlog of cases at over 60 000
there's no sign of this coming down and
I guess the concern here is that this is
yet another conservative government
distracted by Scandal and not getting to
grips with really pressing issues that
the country is having to face well what
I would say is I think that and I don't
think anyone disputes us that Don Robb
did a very effective job as the Justice
section there's an X excellent successor
in the form of Alex chalk who has many
years
the context of this Sophie I think
because as you and in America I did not
helping I think as you and all your
viewers will know is there is a reason
for this high level of backlog which is
the inability of the courts to operate
as normally during the the that's not
true because
the backlog started before that pandemic
of course there were challenges but it
it has been made a lot worse by uh
covert we are working through it for
example extending court hours the
continuing digitalization process for
our courts so work is uh ongoing on that
there are there are deep problems which
we're seeking to address I don't think
that the the change in the person of the
Lord chance or Justice secretary is
going to impact that I mean I guess
shouldn't impact it people
were in conclusions because it does feel
that we are effectively spending so much
time and energy talking about these
ongoing kind of scandals if you like it
another the findings from the review
Into the appointment for the BBC
chairman Richard Sharp due imminently
now of course you'll say this as a
matter for the BBC but it's not that
simple is it because concerns around the
appointment of Richard Sharp are about
the fact that he failed to declare his
involvement in facilitating a loan to
Boris Johnson who went ahead to
recommend him for that job
if there is found to be wrongdoing in
that process should he step down
well so if you won't be surprised for me
to say to you that there is this ongoing
uh investigation into the the nature of
his appointment and I'm certainly not
going to preempt that by by saying how
Richard Sharp should respond to it what
I will say is that as the the Secretary
of State uh responsible for his
appointment uh I think we as a
department went ran the appointment
process well we ran it transparently and
I have every confidence that the inquiry
will uphold that process as being the
right it wasn't that transparent was it
because he didn't declare the loan he's
admitted himself and have had to
apologize for it also concerns about the
recruitment process were raised before
when you're a culture secretaries you
say in October 2020 there was a letter
from the former BBC chairman sir David
Clementi to you who said the committee
is also concerned about the appointments
of my successor as chair we were
concerned about the very strong press
reports that the government even before
the job had been advertised was in
discussion with a preferred candidate
including discussion about salary
I mean you can see how this looks and I
know this wasn't about Richard Charles
itself but you can see how this looks
right the government trying to press its
own candidates on people who agrees
politically with some would worry that
this is them effectively trying to
control the BBC how did you respond to
this letter
well as of you often do on this show and
I don't blame you you flash up someone
something on the the screen behind me uh
and unless you want me to pause for
about 10 seconds to read it
was like raising concerns
this is why there has been an inquiry
set up into the the conduct of the
appointment I have every confidence that
it was a transparent and open process in
terms of this idea that somehow the
conservatives are packing uh public
appointments most of the the complaints
that I found when I was responsible for
for public appointments several years
ago that it was it was the same the
still the same old uh Merry-Go-Round of
Labor cronies who were managing to get
top public appointments I don't think
the facts uh bear out that somehow
conservatives are are skewing the public
appointments process I really don't
think that's the case Okay so we've got
concerns about doing it RAV concerns
over the BBC and obviously it's a really
smooth things over to show that this is
a scrupulous government that's above any
Scandal Boris Johnson is reportedly
about to put his own father into the
honors list
it's I mean that is astonishing isn't it
well so if you really wouldn't expect me
to to comment on the honest process
that's an independent process which I'm
I'm doesn't sound that independent on
that's a problem right there's the there
is a there is a set process whereby
former Prime Ministers are able to
nominate people that they wish to have
uh on us and then that goes through a
proper process even if they're family
members I I cannot say one way or or the
other on that so please don't take it
one way or the other that there's a
proper process for that do you not think
it would look
a bit odd
the father of a former prime minister
was given an honor by his son well so if
you are you're putting forward a
hypothetical it's not that hypothetical
I'm not just plucking this out with
thinner hair I think I think actually we
saw with the um investigation into the
conduct of John robbers an awful lot of
speculation that turned out not to be
the case in the end and it's for
precisely that reason that I don't
respond to speculation understood okay
well voters are going to have a chance
to make their thoughts clear on all this
very soon they're local elections in
England and Northern Ireland in a few
weeks and of course you resigned as
concept a party chair last year in June
I can't believe that wasn't even a year
ago after some bad election results you
said someone must take responsibility I
just want to have a look at the polling
uh over that time because you can see
that the polling is actually now worse
for the conservative party than it was
when you uh resigned
if it's this bad on the local elections
do you think Greg hands the party
chairman should have to respond as well
well first of all I really found this
when I was party chairman
polls come and go they go up and down
key things are the tests of the the
British people and there'll be a test of
the British people uh on the May the 4th
on that election day and that's where
you can see what the results are from
that of course it's a challenging a
backdrop uh overall the conservatives
are still broadly in a midterm situation
and when we previously fought those
seats uh we were in a different position
so there is an expectation of about a
thousand or so seats lost but what I
would say is that my experience of
working with with Rishi sunak as prime
minister is he has brought a calmness
and a stability and an order to
government he's methodically dealing
with problems and I'm finding that
people are responding positively to that
of course there are challenges and of
course there's a way to go but I feel
that we are in heading in the right
direction and I I hope that the British
people will respond to that in those
elections which of course are also I
should say on on local issues primarily